improve your web dev skills by coding a
retro snake game using HTML CSS and
JavaScript you'll learn how to use
JavaScript to draw the game board create
the snake and randomly generate food
make the snake move increase the snake
size when it eats and a bunch of other
features adamir is great at breaking
down concepts for beginners and he
teaches this course we are making this
retro snake game inspired by the iconic
Nokia snake game we will style this
awesome retro design using HTML and CSS
then we'll set up our game logic we'll
draw the game board create the snake and
food elements we'll learn how to make
the snake move and increase its size
when the snake eats as well as increase
its speed to make the game more fun and
challenging we're also going to learn
how to keep score of our snake size as
the game progresses and also to track
when the snake collides with the walls
or itself we are we are also keeping
track of the largest our snake has ever
been in our high score so when we do
lose a game we can keep track of what we
need to beat the next time around by the
end of this tutorial you will have made
the best snake game on YouTube from
scratch and you will understand all the
JavaScript that makes it run and this
video is intended for beginners to
JavaScript as I will be explaining all
the code we use to make this game take
Life by the end you will have learned to
create and manipulate HTML elements
using JavaScript and you will have
learned simple game logic and design and
we will be using VSS code as our code
editor Google fonts for our retro font
as well as an AI generated image for our
snake game logo as always you can find
deployed game and GitHub repo in the
description below if you're ready to
make your own addictive version of the
very best snake game you will find on
YouTube let's get started the first
thing we're going to do is open up our
vs code open an empty project I am just
going to create a new folder on my
desktop and I am going to rename that to
snake game and I'm going to drag that
into vs code so now we have that open in
our Explorer the first thing we are
making is our index file so new file
we're going to create an
index.html file and then we are going to
write exclamation mark and then we get
these shortcuts here with emit
abbreviation we're going to hit the
first uh the single exclamation mark to
give us some boilerplate HTML let's give
it a title of let's say snake
game save
that and then let's actually if you
don't have that install already there's
an extension tab here you can look for
live
server by which we day so install that
uh if you don't have that installed
that's going to enable us to run this
game uh live without having to kind of
refresh the page to get the latest
changes and also to make some of the
JavaScript work we're going to need to
run it live so let's hit that little go
live button and you'll have that if you
installed the extension and that is
opening up our browser here here as we
can see snake game is written in the top
here so we see that is correctly
rendering the little HTML that we have
so far then I'm going to go in here in
View and I'm going to turn on word wrap
to get all the text neatly visible on
the screen let's now also create our CSS
our style. CSS file and let's also just
create our script
.js file uh while we are at it those are
the three files we need nothing else now
let's link these files up with each
other so in the head of our HTML under
the title we are going to first link to
the
stylesheet and writing link we can now
choose the third option which is going
to give us the standard way of writing a
stylesheet and we've already cheated a
bit because we've called it exactly what
the standard is so now let's just check
that by writing body in our
stylesheet and some curly brackets and
giving it a background color of red
hitting save and we see that that is
updating correctly so let's just remove
that for
now same thing with uh the script we're
going to link that up now writing script
script and Source third one and here
we're going to give it
script.js and hit save so here let's try
console logging a shortcut is just
writing log and hitting enter or tab
depending on your um system
preferences and that gives us the full
console log so we're going to console
log
test and then in our browser we're going
to
inspect and we're going to go up to the
console here and we see that we have
test indeed getting uh logged so it is
working as
well let's now remove that back in our
index file let's also be sure to write
uh the defer
attribute inside of the script opening
script tag which is going to say that
it's going to run the script after it
has run everything in the HTML which is
going to help us avoid a lot of error
and that also makes us be able to put
the script neatly in the head which is
the best
practice so inside the body we're going
to write a
div and that is just not going to have
any class or anything but inside of that
div we're going to write another div and
it is going to have the class of
scores that is going to keep our score
then inside of here we are going to have
an H1
it is going to have an ID of
score and here we can just put that to 0
0 for now and also another
H1 with an
ID of let's see high score with capital
S and we're also going to put that
initialize that as 0 0 0 then under this
div we're going to create another div
and it is going to have a class
of game
border
one and hit enter or tab so what just
happened well I used emit
abbreviation um and you can actually
create a div and if you write div and
then dot that dot signals that that's
going to be a whatever you write after
here is going to be the class name so
like so so that can save you a bit of
typing inside the game border one we are
going to create the game border two cuz
it's getting a bit meta here we have
some nice borders around our main um
game board and we're simply using these
divs to style and give them different
colors and
borders so this one is going to be game
border
2 and then third
one with a class of game border
let's see three and inside of the third
game border we're creating the div that
is actually going to have the ID of game
board like so so obviously we don't see
anything yet CU we haven't given them
any style whatsoever or any properties
they don't have any height no width
nothing then just above the closing body
tag we're going to create another
H1 it's going to have an ID of
instruction
text and that is going to be the one
that says press space bar to start the
game like so and then also under there
we're going to have an
image and that is going to have let's
see the alt is going to be the Snake
logo so we don't have the image just now
but if you look in the description there
will be a link to the Snake logo image
this is free of use it's an AI generated
image so feel free to use it for your
project so go in the description uh look
for the snake image uh link download it
and then drag that into the um
repository here I'm doing the same it's
called snake game AI gen
PNG so now in our source attribute here
in the image we can uh link to that so
snake game AI gen and we hit save there
we go cool so now we can move on to our
style. CSS let's actually first before
we move on let's target both the H1 and
the image and just comment those out if
you hit uh control
KC that's going to comment that out or
command KC for on
Mac and then we hit save because um we
are hiding and unhiding those elements
on our in our JavaScript later but in
the meantime uh just to make it a bit
easier for us to see what's going on
we're just going to hide them for now so
now we can pop up into our style. CSS
file let's also inspect in our browser
and we can stay in the elements I'm
going to open the body here the div just
so you can see that we have all the
elements here we have our game
border with literally no
properties all these no properties
they're just empty divs so now we're
going to give these div more life and
make this actually look like a game so
body going to Target that first we are
going to say display
Flex so that we can have things neatly
under each other and centered we're
going to align it align items to the
center we are going to justify the
content to the center as well this is
going to align items uh both uh
vertically and horizontally to the
center then we're going to give the body
the height of 100 view height so it
takes the entire
height of the
screen then we are going to give it a
margin because by default you see we
have this scroll bar here that's because
the body as you can see here when I
hover over it has this orange by default
margin of what is it uh 8
pixels so we're going to remove that and
say zero and that removes the scroll
bar then we are going to give a fult
family which is going to be something
we're going to get from Google fonts to
make these numbers and the text we write
more game like more retro and more like
pixelated we are going to get that from
fonts. goole.com it's completely free to
use and quite easy in Google fonts
you're going to search font you're going
to write
VT and then you're going to see this
vt323 that is the font we're going to be
using if you scroll down you're going to
see a select Reg 400 you're going to hit
that and then you're going to go in the
top right corner you going see we have
that selected you're going to copy this
link here we're going to head over to
the
index.html file Under The Meta tags here
and over the title you're going to paste
that in and then this preconnect stuff
basically loads the the font a bit
sooner and then this link redirects to
the correct font hosted on Google
fonts so here we're telling our
stylesheet that basically now you have
access to this font and how we use it is
we use this CSS rule here so we can copy
that head back to our CSS and let's also
go back to our snake game we have our
zeros here if we save the CSS we see
that it reloads because of the live
server now when I paste in here the font
family we see that we get our nice retro
design cool now we are ready to move on
so next we're going to Target our body
as well as our DOT snake class that we
haven't used yet but we're going to be
using in our JavaScript so we're just
going to Target it at the same time we
are giving them a background color that
is quite dark uh so it's hash
which gives us this uh dark grayish
color then we are also going to Target
the ID game board game
dashboard and we're going to give it a
border radius of 100
pixels we are going to give it a display
of
grid so this is where we're actually
making the game board with this grid and
then we're going to give it a grid
template columns so how many columns is
this grid going to have well it's going
to be repeat 20 columns and each of them
are going to be 20 pixels
wide and then same with rows grid
template
rows that is going to be repeat 20 by 20
pixels like so so let's check out our
body
now game board game board two border
game board here we
go can we see that okay so we see now
that we have if we hover over game board
here we see that we actually see the
game board it is 400 * 400 pixels wide
and um size basically and it has 20 * 20
a little squares in inside of it so
that's the grid we just
made this is our playing field that
we're going to be using throughout the
game lastly here we're going to also
give it a margin of five
pixels because later on we are going to
have a border here and this margin
basically makes it so that our snake
when it hits the Border it's not going
to overlap the border and it's going to
create a neat um uh visual aesthetic so
it's simply for visuals this margin then
we're going to Target the game border
one and we are going to say we're going
to give it a border of
hashtag and that's going to be 5
f43 and that's going to be a solid
border and it's going to be 10 pixels
wide there we
go and and then we're going to give it a
border radius of 30 pixels to round that
out a
bit as well as a box shadow of inset and
I'm going to explain in a bit why we're
using box Shadow here in addition to uh
the Border but it's easier to see once
we actually have some more elements this
is also going to be 10 pixels and it's
going to be the color of it's going to
be the same color actually 59 5
f43 save that so you slightly see the
the Border here so if I comment that out
control
KC you see that the Border actually goes
on the outside of the game board whilst
the if I comment this in again you see
that the uh box shadow goes on the
inside
it's a bit hard to see because it covers
it but you see that the border is
basically here so the Border goes out
the box shadow box shadow goes in and
because we have different radiuses on
these different game borders without the
Box Shadow it would basically give a a
little gap between one and the other so
that's why we're adding a box shadow in
addition to a border but I can show you
that and then you'll see why so let's
just call copy this whole game border
one down so shift alt down or shift
option down if you're on Mac and you can
hit that twice and I'm just going to
copy that
code so let's say game border two and
game border three hit
save and now let's alter it so it's the
correct colors so here it's going to
be um let's see a
BB
a and we're going to give that the same
color here A B B 78 a and the third one
is going to
be 8 B 9 66 C and the same color for the
Box
Shadow there we go hit save now we can
see the difference between them so now
let me me remove the Box
Shadows like so by commenting them out
hitting save and that's here you can see
why we are adding those box Shadows
because we're avoiding that little Gap
there because these have different
border radiuses if they had matching
border radiuses but they don't and we
don't want to have it either because
that's the visual aesthetic that gives
it that more uh cartoony and
Vibe so let's comment that back
again but we're going to change the um
the different properties here in game
border 2 The Box radius is going to be
pixels in game border three the Box
radius is going to be 20
pixels like
so and in game border two it's going to
be for the Border it's going to be not
10 pixels but
8 and for the third one it's not going
to be 10 but
30 like so let's see if we can see the
allall there we go starting to look more
like it and the same here in the third
uh game border 3 the Box Shadow is not
going to be 10 pixels but five so that
is all for the borders now let's move on
to the instructions
text
instruction
text then we are going to Let's comment
back these in the
index.html so control
KU that's going to make them show up
again so just to see
them then we are going to position
it we're going to position it
absolute like
so we're going to position it from the
top
60% we are going to give it the color of
#
333 we are going to give it a
width of 300 pixels which makes it also
um fold under each other
we're going to text align it to the
center we are also going to text
transform this to capitalize to
capitalize each
word we're going to give it a padding of
pixels and we're going to give it a
margin of
zero these are all just simple stylistic
choices just to to make it look good uh
it's not still not looking good because
we have this snake image here that is
still positioned relative to the other
elements whilst the positioning of
absolute kind of frees it to be just
positioned within the
frame so now we're going to Target the
scores as well that's our two scores up
here we are going to say display of
flex and then we are going to justify
the content to
space between like so then we are going
to Target the
score and we're going to give it a
color of hasht
ABB
788 gives us that nice
green then we are going to Target both
score
and
high score capital
S and we're going to give it a font size
of 40
pixels we're going to give it a
font
weight of
[Music]
Boulder and we're going to give it a
margin
of 10
pixels and
zero hm why is
the they should not be so score should
be on this side and high score should be
here but it's not happening so this
scores here is not targeting
properly let's see
class ah I see I think yeah okay so this
is a class as we can see here class
scores and we have defined it as an ID
here so let's just remove the hashtag
and another the
dot and that solves it there we
go looking way way better and as
intended now let's target only the high
score again remember capital S we're
going to give it a color of
Hash
d8 D D
CA like so bit more whiter but still on
the green
scale and we are going to give it a
display for now of none cuz until we
start the game the first time and
actually um hit into something so we can
save the score we had we're going to
kind of remove the high score to give
more of a visual um um element to it so
there's something new happening once you
actually have played the game then we
are going to Target the game border 3
together with the logo and we're going
to give both of them a background color
of hasht C4
cf3 starting to look good then we are
going to Target the
snake and we're going to give it a
background color we're not going to be
able to see this yet now but uh we're
going to see it soon once we start with
our JavaScript 41 41
41 actually we have that already here so
we don't need that let's remove
that we're going to give it simply a
border of #
five A5 A5 a one pixel and that's going
to be dotted there then we're are
targeting the snakes
food and that is going to have a
background
color of
hhde
DDE as well as a
border of #
9995 pixels and
solid and then lastly in the CSS we're
going to Target the logo and we are
going to position it absolute straight
in the
middle H we did we
add we didn't add the class in the HTML
so go to the HTML and then the image
we're going to give it a class of logo
sorry an ID of
logo save that and then we see we have
something looking better here now we are
ready to move on to our JavaScript so
let's save the style and the index and
then we can open our script file and the
first thing we're going to do here is
we're going to Define HTML
elements that we need from uh the HTML
that we're going to manipulate here in
the JavaScript so the first we're going
to uh get a hold of is the game board
because we need it to do anything in the
game so we're going to Define that using
the cost and we're going to say we're
going to give that board as a name and
then we're going to use the
document property and then the get
element by ID
method so then here we're saying uh the
constant board that is going to be
equivalent to if you go into the
document that means the entire page here
the entire HTML document and then you
get the element by the ID and then let's
go to the HTML and see what the ID is
game board so let's copy
that and head over back to our script
and then be sure to add some brackets
here and gameboard and hit
save and then let's log that just to
test log board and then let's inspect
go into our console and we see that it
has successfully logged the game board
with a div uh with the ID of game board
so it works
cool let's remove that and it disappears
so then we are ready to start actually
the functions of our game so we're ready
to start the game well we can't start
the game just yet because we first we
actually need to draw the map so we're
going to create a function
called
Draw and this essentially is going to
draw let's see draw game map it's going
to draw the snake and also the
food so we are going to first we're
going to take the event that if we have
started this game before we're going to
need to reset the board so we're
targeting the board we just made here
and we're going to say inner
HTML and we're going to say set that to
just empty strings so that it's
empty so then every time we draw this
board is going to be
reset then we are going to call another
function because we're going to draw our
snake so we don't have this function
made but that's what we're going to make
just now so so next thing we're going to
draw
Snake by defining this function we just
used or called function draw
Snake and inside of
here we are going to need basically to
Define how our snake looks and the way
we are doing that is by actually using
um an array an object inside of it so if
we go back to the top here under the
const
board we are going to
also
Define game
variables and here we're going to say
let snake and we're using the let and
not the const because the board stays
the same but the snake is going to
change in
size so let snake equals an array with
one object object inside and that object
or in fact all the objects that the
snake is going to have throughout the
game is going to be um positions within
the game map so it's going to have an X
position that is going to be
10 and it's going to have a y position
that is also going to be
10 this essentially if we go back and we
inspect our game map
here we see that we have a game board
and it has 20 rows and 20 columns so the
10th row and the 10th column more oress
in the middle is going to be where the
snake
starts so that is what we have defined
here let snake is this
position now currently it's only a
position it's nothing else there's
there's nothing tying it to the game
board but we'll get to that so now we
are uh continuing with our draw Snake
function inside of
here we are going to take the snake that
we just made and we're going to say four
each which is an array method so we're
going to say for each of the children it
has in here so for everything that is
inside this array so now it's just one
object so that's going to be for each
object which is just one
for
now we're going to say for all for all
those segments for each segment do
something we're going to call an arrow
function and inside of here we're
basically running some code on every
single element that is inside of the
snake so at the start of the snake is
just one dot so what are we going to do
well we're going to define a new const
here we're going to say snake l
element is equal to
create
game element this is something we
haven't as a function that we haven't
made yet but we're going to make shortly
so we're going to say create game
element you're going to create a
div and then that div is going to have
the snake class
let's also go to view and word wrap like
so so basically this function that we're
going to create is going to be
responsible for creating every snake
element and for giving it the snake
class it's going to be a div with a
snake class that we have already styled
here in our CSS that has a border and
the background
color and that essentially gives the
illusion in a way that there is a snake
on the board here so before we move on
here and do something with the snake
element let's actually make that
function so it's going to be the
function that is responsible for
creating a snake and or or food Cube or
div so that's going to be the
function create game element
and it is going to take uh an
argument tag and it's going to take
class
name so as we can see here create G
element we're giving it a div and we're
giving it the class name snake so that's
the tag is a div and the class name is
the
snake and then we're going to say
const
element
is equal to document dot
create
[Music]
element like
so
tag so inside of the create G element we
are creating a new constant element that
is using the same way to Target the the
HTML but here instead of targeting an
existing element by ID like we did here
we're actually just creating a new uh
HTML element inside of our JavaScript
that's what this inbuilt method
does and we are saying that you should
create a tag and the tag is whatever is
sent in here in this
position and we can see here that the
div is sent in so here B essentially
what is saying here is document create
element div when it's used like this
this but if we used it somewhere else or
if we change that to P that would be a
paragraph that would be created then we
are going to go into the element that we
just created we're going to go to the
class name of the element and we're
going to give it the same as class name
so this might be a bit confusing because
this is what we call the um argument
here in the the function but it's also
the same name as what the actual um
property on this element is so class
name is also the inbuilt definition of a
just simple class which is what we use
in um
HTML but essentially what we're doing
here is we're taking this snake here
inside of the great game element and
we're adding that to the div that we are
creating as the class so what this does
is creates a div with the class name of
snake and then we need to also return
this element that we just
made like
so so now con snake element is
equivalent to a div with a class of
snake then we can move on inside of the
draw Snake function so the next thing
we're going to do then is we're going to
call another uh function that we haven't
made yet so it's going to be set
position and here
oops set position is also going to
basically take similar arguments snake
element and also segment let's scroll
down and create that set position
function what this set position is going
to do is going to set
the
position of the
snake or the
food so once we've made it it's going to
actually set it on the game
board or actually Define the position
it's going to have on the game board so
we're going to create that set
position and that's going to take the
arguments of
element as well as position and inside
of there we're going to take the element
we're going to go into the style of it
and we are going to say grid
column is going to be equal to
position
X so essentially what we're doing here
we see that we are using the set
position here we have created the snake
element we created create a div with a
class of snake then we're sending that
into set position and that's the element
here so here we're we have a div class
snake I'm going into its style we're
going into this grid column which is a
CSS uh property and we're setting that
equal to position dox so what is
position well here we're sending in
segment and segment if you remember is
for each segment here that's basically
every single object here that is a
coordinate inside of the snake so as the
snake
grows basically it's going to have many
of these uh object inside but at the
start it's just X10 y10 so that's what
we are sending in here so position X
means this position here 10
because position is
this and that is this segment and
segment is simply
this so segment
X segment
y position
X segment X okay I hope that makes sense
um we are going to see that soon in
action and then it's going to be more
clear to see what is going on we also
need to set the element.
style grid
row and then we set that to position
y so that we both have the X which is
the horizontal coordinate and also the y
coordinate which is the vertical now
let's actually see how this works uh in
practice so now let's actually go to the
draw Snake function under set position
we are going to Target the
board we are going to append child we're
going to actually take the board element
the HTML board here and we're going to
add the snake that we just
created snake element like
so now if we actually call this function
draw we should be able to see our snake
element
so
testing draw
function draw we're not going to call it
like this but just to test if it works
and then let's also remove our two texts
here so we can
see like so there we go there's our
snake let's go back to the script let's
comment out our draw
function there is no snake and once we
call the
draw we see in the game board we have a
div class snake and look at the style
here if you can read that it's small I
know but if you can look it there has
style grid area 10 * 10 if I now edit
this in the element dot style
here and I change that to let's say two
you see that it goes here
one here 2 3 4 and it goes gradually
down if I give it a one
two if I give it a 20 it's at the end 18
so that is what we have been positioning
here you can also do that directly in
the JavaScript if we change that to 20
and 20 that should be the bottom right
like so and
120 should be the bottom uh left like
so so I hope it makes a bit more sense
and pat yourself on the back we just
made our first snake element we made the
snake head so now we can actually remove
this I'm just going to comment it out
for now and we are going to create our
actual food as well so
draw
food like so inside of the draw food
we're going to create a
const called food
element which is going to be equal to
using that create game element function
again we are going to create a div but
this time instead of snake it's going to
have a a class of
food which we are of course targeting in
our CSS then we are going to set
position so this is as you can see it is
similar to the draw Snake uh
function so set
position we are also using the already
made uh function we're going to give it
the food
element as the element and then for the
position we're going to give it
food which we haven't made yet so let's
make that if we scroll back up under let
snake we're going to say let
food equals and because food is going to
be automatically generated it's not
going to have the same position every
time cuz that would be boring wouldn't
make a very fun game we are going to
call a function here to give it a
randomize
position so generate
food is going to be called here we have
not created this so let's copy that
name and create a function generate food
and let's just leave that blank for
now continuing inside of the draw food
function we also need to actually append
this food to the actual board so board
append
child and then food element like so so
it's pretty much the same setup as in
the draw
Snake now in actually to actually get
this food position uh cuz now it's not
going to work it's not getting the
function is not returning anything so
let's move on to our gener generate food
function let's also just comment here
this is draw
food
function inside of our generate food
function we are going to create a new
constant called X which is going to be
its X position we are going to use the
inbuilt math object here which has some
cool inbuilt methods like random which
gives us a random number uh in
JavaScript so this is currently just
going to give us math random is going to
give you a random number between zero
and up to one not including one though
so it's going to be 0.1 0 uh 39 0.
99.9999 so everything apart from one so
0 to up to one then we are going to
times that times 20 we could do that
like uh put 20 here because we know the
grid size is 20 but let's rather go up
to our game variables and let's just
Define a new constant
here call it grid size equals
20 and then we can use that here instead
so if we want to change the grid size
later we can easily do that here and
then because we are getting this math
random you know up from zero we don't
want a zero position cuz the grid starts
at one right so we're just going to take
all of
that and we are going to plus
one but then we also have a new problem
is that this is basically giving us um
not whole numbers it's giving us commas
so we need to also use something called
math floor on it which basically takes
whatever this expression is and it
floors it so if it's
1.99 it's going to turn into one if it's
3.20 it's going to turn into three so
that's what the math floor
does and the one at the end is simply to
raise this from zero to start from one
all the way up to 20 so that gives us
the X it's going to be the exact same
thing for the Y so let's just copy that
call it Y and then we are going to
return this as an
object X and
Y and save that so now generate food
returns a random coordinate in X and Y
position let's draw the function again
let's uncomment the draw function and
let's see let's see generate food are we
actually using it
anywhere I see we have not added the
draw food uh function here
so we haven't actually called this
function ever we're calling the
draw but we're not calling the draw food
inside of it so draw food
like
so there we go now we have our snake if
I hit save again here it should as it is
doing giving us a random position for
our food uh di here how cool is that so
now when we start a game it has a random
position well snake is always at 10 10
okay now let's move on to actually
getting this snake to move let me just
comment here generate food it's a bit
self-explanatory but we've started
commenting every function so we might as
well continue next one is going to
moving the
snake so function
move it's going to be called and then
inside of that function we're going to
create a new constant we're going to
call it head and this is basically going
to be the head of the snake but it's not
the direct head uh it's not actually
this object here the first object we
don't want to manipulate that uh we want
to make something that is called a
shallow copy because if we don't then
we're basically going to run into some
problems very usual in JavaScript where
you don't actually want to alter the
original object or the original array we
want to use the position of the head but
we don't want to actually alter it so we
are going to call the spread operator on
the
snake zero which is going to be the head
here cuz in an object it's zero index
base so the first object or in an array
sorry the first position in the index is
zero so we're getting a hold of the
snake zeroth position which is 10 10 and
we're simply spreading it into this new
object this is basically a copy of this
but it is not changing this otherwise we
could just call it like
this but if you try doing that you're
going to see that it's not working and
you're going to run into some uh weird
uh Behavior basically then we're going
to create a switch statement
here where we are taking the
direction of the
snake now we haven't made this yet we're
going to create it now and the direction
in the start if we go up to the game
variables here
let
direction is going to be by default to
the
right let's scroll back down so we're
taking the direction we're running a
switch case on it and inside of the
switch case we're going to have
different uh cases so if the case is
like it is now
let's see
right then we're going to take the
head and we're going to say take the
head take its X
position and you are going
to iterate that or you're going to
increment that what that mean means is
you're going to increase it by one so if
you press
right you're going to go into the x
coordinate that's here that's X and
you're going to go one up so that's from
this place to that place which kind of
fits if you're going right you want to
go right so that is what this is doing
so the direction by default is going to
start moving the snake in the right
direction we need a couple of more cases
though well we need three
more so let's
just copy those
in so if the case is up we're going to
actually go to the y
coordinate and we are going to go Y and
decrement because the position up here
is
one and if we go if we press actually
from the start it's 10 if we go up we're
going closer to one so we actually want
to go down in uh numbers so that's why
this might seem a bit counterintuitive
but it makes sense then we're going to
take that down then it's going to go Y
++ and then left is going to be x -
minus now we have the start of our move
function but we're missing something
here so basically here we
are um moving the head but here we are
actually taking the head we are un
shifting
it and we're giving it the head
so what unshift does is it basically
adds a head object to the beginning of
the snake array so this head here which
is a copy of the original
head it is basically putting that at the
start of the snake array here so now it
only has
one um object here but when we for
example go uh uh up we are going to be
pushing or un shifting a new uh object
inside of here so up would be X same y
it would be nine so that's what happens
if you would to press up from the start
of the game and that is what we are
doing here uh after the snake unshift we
want to also take the snake
pop like
so because what we are doing here when
we're moving as you might have noticed
if we're un Shifting the head we're
adding a new part to the snake we are
actually just elongating the snake so if
we were to move 1 2 3 4 you would see
that the snake doesn't move it just
grows in that direction so that's why
we're also taking the snake and we're
calling pop on it because as you can see
here it removes the last element from an
array so when we go right let's say we
are adding a piece here but we're
removing the last piece so it gives this
illusion we're actually just building a
snake a new elements in One Direction
and we're removing the elements behind
it so it gives the illusion of movement
but actually it's just being rebuilt and
destroyed uh one after the other now
let's simply test this function test
moving so we're going to call a set
interval uh in build
function because we want to move more
than
once and we want to call the move
function that we just
made so that's going to move first
and then we want to draw
again cuz uh if we don't draw then we're
not going to see the new changes so then
draw
again new
position and let's also comment that out
like
so and then finally we also need to have
a time on this so let's give it a 200
milliseconds and as you can see now when
I start the game and I reload for every
200 M seconds or 1/5 of a second the
snake is moving in the direction of
Direction which we have put to right
let's change that to
up as we can see it goes up and then
down let's
say working
left
working so you can choose whichever you
want to have by default I'm just leaving
it as a right so cool our moving
function works so now we are actually
ready to also make the
snake uh become bigger if it hits the uh
food and it's actually quite simple and
elegant solution so as I told you if I
uncomment this now look what happens
the snake by default just grows because
that's actually the move is actually
more of a grow function it is that we
remove the last part so the only thing
we need to uh do to make the snake grow
when it hits the uh food is to just
remove this function when it hits the
same coordinates as the food element so
let's just take this away let's uh
comment that out so we can uh see what's
going on let's go back inside of the
move
function under this snake pop we're
actually going to comment that
out we are going to create an if
statement and if
head remember that's what we defined
here as the shallow copy if the head x
coordinate is equal to the
food x coordinate and as you can
remember the food we have here randomly
generated that's this coordinate
here so if those two are
equal
and head Y is equal to food
y so basically if they're on the same
spot then we're going to run some code
so
then we're going to say food
equals generate food because that means
that we have run into the food so we
need a new food placed on the
map so then that would happen so if we
hit it it's going to create a new random
location for the food then we also want
to uh clear the interval it's another
inbuilt method or
function because otherwise we're also
going to run into some um issues and
it's basically we just want to reset the
movement and the whole uh move function
here otherwise uh a lot of bugs are
going to
happen so we're
clearing clear past interval then we
want to go into the game interval which
we have not defined
yet we going to go back up to our
variables we are going to Define let
game
interval and we're just going to Define
it that it
exists and we're going to go down here
it's keeping track of when we are
running the our game basically so we're
going to take the game interval we're
going to set it to a new interval cuz we
already had paused the other
one and here we are going to
run some code we're going to run a new
move we're going to reset that we are
going to also run a new draw and reset
that and then we are going
to add that we're going to add the
game
speed
delay because instead of uh setting it
to 200 here we might want to change it
which we actually do when we eat a food
we are decreasing this delay and thereby
increasing the game speed so we also
need to Define this let
game speed delay and we're going to
start with 200
milliseconds so then scrolling back
down then if our
head is on the same position as the food
we generate a new food and we then skip
the snake
pop so snake pop is not happening here
and
thereby this one uh div snake is going
to turn into a two div snake it's going
to basically turn into the
position uh of the food else we are
going to run the snake
pop so I hope that makes sense basically
if we don't run into food we're going to
be continuously building building the
snake One Direction and then we're
moving the snake back or the tail and
then if we hit the food we're just going
to not remove the tail and therefore the
snake is going to grow now we're going
to move on to actually creating our
start game
function which is going to be called
originally start game inside of the
start game
function we we are going
to use the game started variable that we
are going to create and we're going to
set it to true so let's scroll
up and let's create let
game started and initially it's going to
be set to false like
so and then when we start the game it's
going to be set to true so here we're
going to basically keep track
of a running game that's going to be
very
useful um to enable us to basically if
we want to start the game we want to hit
enter and we don't want to be able to
start the game over again while the game
is running things like that so it's very
useful to keep track of if it's running
or
not then we want to take the
instruction we haven't defined those
either let's scroll up and let's get a
hold of
const
instruction text
equals
document get element by
ID and we are going to Target the
instruction
text let's just see if we gave that
correctly let's also uncomment them in
the JavaScript code
so now we see that they are taking the
space and we want to actually hide them
when we start the game so yeah
instruction text let's just copy that
for safety and paste that in there we
also want to define a
const logo
document equals
document get mement by
ID and that's going to be
logo like
so now we scroll down and we can use
them here in the start game so
instruction text we are going to go into
that
style and
display and we are going to set that to
none
when we start let's also shift all down
and we're going to do the same with the
logo so when we start the game we're
going to hide these two and basically
we're going to get then view the snake
and the food again
unobstructed then we are also going to
go to the game interval and we're going
to set the new
interval
and when we start we're going to call
the
move we are going to call the check
Collision function that we haven't made
yet
collision and we're going to also call
the
draw and that is also going to be run on
the game speed delay
like so let's comment out the check
Collision for now that is the function
we're going to create to basically see
if the snake is running into the corners
or into itself but let's not get ahead
of ourselves we're going to create that
later so for now it's just comment that
out and let's also we are calling draw
here in our start game let's go up to
line
45 let's um comment that out
like so then we are ready to actually
make to start our game so here it says
press space bar well if we do that
nothing happens because we're not
listening for the space bar that's what
we're going to create now we're going to
create a key press
listener event
listener like so
and that is going to be function
handle key press is taking an
event and inside of
here we are going to call the start game
but not um at any point so if we press
up Arrow we don't want to start the game
we just want to move the the snake so if
the
game started so if the game is not
started with the exclamation
mark and the
event. code
equals
space then we want to let's see like so
then we want to start the game called
that function and this doesn't work for
every browser so we also need to
call let's
see
or like so and let's wrap
these in uh in parentheses like so and
then we
can create another one here let's just
copy
this so if game started an event code
equals space or if game hasn't started
an
event
key is just an empty space like so so
that's going to basically handle um
every browser's um handling of space key
if the game hasn't started and we press
the space then we're going to start the
game else we are going to handle the
arrow keys so another switch case
here and we're going to handle the event
key because that's the event we're
getting in here that's the key we press
first case is going to be Arrow up so
these are the basically the shorthand uh
phrases for the different Keys they're
inbuilt and let's see we want to handle
it like this call on then we're going to
take the
direction and we're going to set that to
up so remember the direction is what we
have defined here it's by default right
but if we press now we're listening to
key presses if we press up it's going to
change to up and that is going to affect
how the move function moves and it's
going to change the direction of the
snake so here we are basically listening
for the handle key press and that sets
the chain of motion for the snake
Direction and then we are going to break
after that then we're going to copy this
down one 2 three times
arrow
down that is going to change it to
down
arrow
left and that is going to be left and
arrow right that is going to be
right like
so and we're breaking out of that switch
case after each uh case then we have our
handle uh key press function ready now
we need to call it so now we're just
going to go to the document we're going
to add an event
listener and we're just going to listen
to that all the time I'm going to listen
to key press actually key
down and for every key down we're going
to call the handle key press so when we
that's the event we take in
here and we're going to call handle key
press so if we have clicked something or
press something that is the space it's
going to call the start game if we click
something else then we are going to move
the um the snake so let's
try enter
it
works how cool reload enter it works and
now I am also hitting the
arrow
keys how cool is that now we have a
snake that is moving let's see if we can
eat and there we go oh we are speeding
up by a
lot that is a bug but we are moving
around around and we are increasing our
size as
well sped up a lot it's hard to eat the
second one in any case we have
successfully started the game we have
successfully changed the direction of
the uh snake and we are making it grow
by eating food we have a bug somewhere
where it's actually increasing the um
speed drastically so let's go to our
uh start game let's
see no that's uh
correct maybe we have something in
our um when we eat it changes when we
eat so here we're also going to call the
uh
check
Collision
function
like so we're just going to comment it
out for
now so be sure to add that uh in the if
statement in the move so game interval
we're setting an interval we
are let's see we're calling the move
we're calling the check Collision we're
calling draw on the game speed
delay else no no it looks good I wonder
if we are
simply
um unknowingly to us we're altering this
game speed delay so let's
just um go into
here into the if statement here we're
going to create a new
function under or over clear interval
we're going to call
increase speed function
and we're going to create that right
away so under our event listener going
to call the function
increase increase
speed and
then we're going to
log
the
game speed
delay let's see now what happens if we
start it's 200
okay 200 okay so it's not to do with the
game
speed
H let's Try by adding the if statement
if game speed
delay is bigger than
150 then we are going to decrease
it like
so by
five let's start
again still speed speing
up very
fast
H let's comment out that start again
it's 200
195 so it has nothing to do with the
game speed delay at least uh I see what
we did wrong okay here in the clear
interval we are actually not clearing
anything we need to clear the actual
interval game interval there we go now
let's see if we start the
game ah there we go now we're also
logging the
speed as we can
see we are
successfully eating food growing the
snake and it is
not um increasing in speed uh
drastically it is increasing in speed
normally as you can see going from 200
to now
155 which is a way more uh normal and
easier way to play the
game and now we've hit
our uh only condition in our speed uh
like increase speed function which is
150 so it's not increasing
more also you can see we don't have the
Collision function working so we can
just walk through our own snake our own
body we can hit the corners nothing
really happens then down again into the
increased speed function let's add an
else if statement here else if game
Speed game speed
delay is bigger than 100
then we're going to run uh
different uh let's see game speed delay
is going to be minus equal to 3 so
basically we're going to decrease the
speed increase the faster it gets so
that it's not going to get to a point
too quickly where it's unplayable
basically but it's still going to
increase incrementally then let's copy
this paste that
there two more
times for the 50 Mark and also the 25
Mark which is starting to become very
very fast so one and
two now if we save and we restart the
game we can
see that when we hit 150 it is going to
be
um decreasing by three instead of five
here we go when we hit under 150 we are
going to 147 144 141 so uh decreasing by
three instead of five which is exactly
what we have coded right now if you're
wondering how I'm resetting the game I'm
simply just saving the script file now
we can go on to actually make our
Collision like check Collision function
that we've been using
uh in at Le at least two places so check
collision and this is going to be the
thing that resets the game if we hit the
wall or we hit our own body so const
head is equal to
snake and zero so here compared to the
spread operator we have up here we are
not uh us using it here we are simply uh
say setting it exactly equal to the
zeroth index of snake namely the
head then
if head X
position is less than one meaning that
it's here is the one meaning is zero
it's going to hit the
wall
or
or head
X is a larger than grid size which is 20
it means it's going to go on the right
side over so it's going to hit either
here or
here so this
one or head
y
is also smaller than
one
or head
Y is bigger than grid
size in that case we are going to
reset
game and that's a function we haven't
made yet
but that function is going to basically
reset our game when we hit uh the
borders of the wall now we need to take
the we need to check also for the times
when it hits itself so here we're going
to need a for
Loop so four we're going to Define
I let I equals one starting at one and I
is going to go towards snake.
length and then when that happens it's
going to increment by
one so what that means is we have an I
that we just randomly defined as one we
just made and I as long as I is smaller
than the snake length which is at the
start it's just uh
one then we are are going to increment
it so we're going to go basically
through the entire snake length that's
the point of this so for every part of
the snake we're going to run a piece of
code that's the point of the for
Loop and then inside of here we're going
to have an if statement and we're going
to check if head
X is equal to
snake in the position of I because the
position of I is going to be starting
with the body and going
upwards so if snake
i
x so here we're checking if the head is
the same position of the snake uh body
in the E
position and the same
snake one I equals
snake I position and y coordinate
because otherwise it might be on the
same position in the X Direction here
but it might not be in the Y so we need
to check for
both unless it's uh hitting on both the
X and the Y it's not in the same exact
position but if it is we're also going
to reset the game then we are we going
to create our reset game
function reset
game also let's go and uncomment the
check Collis we have let's see by
searching for it contrl
f we're going to
remove those comments
here and
here there we go now we're using it
now we just need to create the reset
game function inside of
here we are going to
call the
snake and we are going to reset
that to its original uh position
x equals
10 we need to create a object in here x
= 10 and Y =
10 we're also going to take the
food and we're going to reset that by
generating the food again
randomly we're going to reset the
direction to
right which was its original
position and we're also going to reset
the game speed delay to its original 200
when that happens when we reset the game
we also want to update the
score so
update
score let's make that function right now
function update
score we're going to create a constant
here
current
score is equal to
snake dot length the length of the
snake Min - one because the snake length
starts at one so we don't want to start
the square at one all the time we just
want to start it at zero makes more
sense but you're free to
choose then we want to go go into the
score that we have made up
here oh we haven't actually we haven't
made that yet so let's create a constant
score is equal to
document dot get element by
ID and it's going to Target the score
element and here we're going to go into
that element we are going to go into the
text content
and we are going to set that equals to
the current score two
string and then we are going to pad that
to the
start with
three uh numbers and that's going to be
zero so what does this mean well we're
basically setting the score text content
here equals to the uh snake length and
we're turning that into a
string so that we can also make that a
triple digit number without this PAAD
start it would turn it into one it would
remove the uh two zeros and turn it into
one so this is just simply some flare to
make it a triple digit number and start
uh counting from the end here which is
the P start here it's going to add zeros
if the number is not big enough so if
the number is 20 it's just going to add
one zero if the number is two it's going
to add two zeros then we need to
actually call this function we're going
to go up to our let's
see our
draw and we're going to call the update
score
here now if we start the game let's
try
and there we go we see that we have our
score starting to
tick how
cool now it's starting to become an
addictive
game okay and let me also just
demonstrate if we H remove that and we
said two to the pad
start let's start the
game we see that now we have two numbers
in instead of
three change that back to three like so
but there are more things we want in our
reset game we also want to actually once
we have hit something we want to also
have our high score so we need to also
update
high
score and also stop game
so those are two functions we're going
to create right
now so first let's take the stop game
function so stop
game and inside of here whenever we want
to stop the game we want to actually
clear the interval and what interval the
game
interval
then we want to go into the
game
started and we want to say well now it's
not started anymore now it's
stopped and then we want to go to the
instruction text style
display and we want to say that it's a
block because before it was
hidden and the same with the
logo
we're going to go into the
style
display and we're going to say
block that's for the Stop game then
creating our update high
score we want to then call a constant
current score similar to earlier we're
going to say that it's length actually
snake do length
minus
one then if the current
score
is
bigger than the high
score then we want to set the high
score to current
score now we don't have the score May
yet or the high
score Let's see we are missing the
const
high
score
text equals
document get element by
ID and that's going to be high score
like
so now we have
that we also need to actually Define the
high score in the this is just the
element for the text but we also need to
define the high score here so under our
generate food
let high score equals to zero at the
start now let's scroll back
down so if high score if if current
score is bigger than high score
that's this one if it's bigger than what
we have here it is going to be set as
the new high score that's what we're
doing
here and then we're also going to unhide
the high score
text text
content equals high score
to string and it's the same as last pad
start
and it's going to be three digits and
it's going to be with
zeros then here we are unhiding it high
score text style
display and equals to block so now if we
start the
game and we get a score let's just crash
into something we also see that our
Collision is working and we crashed and
we we had only one in score let's start
again and we
see so now we have
one let's try to get a bit higher number
two high score stays the same but score
is incrementing
three and four and crash and then four
is saved here so now we're starting to
get the real game elements that want
want makes you want to keep playing more
and more so now we have most of our game
done but I don't know if you
see uh when I restart the
game you see that
sometimes the food is generated here and
it doesn't really look good uh like here
we want to have the logo we want to have
like press space bar this food looks a
bit off so the way we're going to do
that we're going to scroll up and we're
going to fix or tweak speak the draw
food function a little
bit so where is it draw food here it
goes so you know how we have this game
started function here well we're
basically going to wrap this draw food
in that in an if statement so
if
game
started then we are going to allow this
uh stuff to happen but but if not well
it's not going to
happen now draw food is only drawing
food if the game is already started and
on this screen it hasn't started until
we press space bar so now if we start
the game over again we can
see that the food actually starts dra uh
drawing rendering on the page once we
have started the
game and now it's not going to show up
and is never going to show up on this
page when we have our logo and our text
showing and there we go let's do a final
trial I am eating the snake eating the
food sorry I am the
snake let's
see and we are successfully growing
let's see if I hit
myself then it's game over high score is
updated score is
reset if I hit the edges same
thing great now we can remove this
console log as
well let's see console log you can just
comment out that
that is everything for our snake game I
hope you enjoyed it I hope you now can
also have fun playing this game you can
also tweak it further if you want there
are many things you could add here you
could customize the way the score is
counted you could add for example if you
are eating food close to the snake body
or the edges that could maybe
potentially give you more score you
could add score a bit depending on the
time that you have been playing so the
more you play the more score you also uh
increase or you could also make it more
um Advanced the way the speed is
increased maybe also based on the score
so there's many things here you could do
to increase and further tweak the game
to your liking you can also change the
style you can change the design of the
snake and the food there's many things
here you could do and I encourage you to
to play around with the uh code that we
now have and make it your own as well um
I really hope you enjoyed this game uh
if you liked uh if you would like to put
it uh online and you don't know how to
do that then here is a video that
explains how to host your game live for
free using netlify and I'm looking
forward to see you in the next video
Until then see you